they call ice the devil's drug
if i had a gun i would have killed
myself asia's meth trade
has exploded and thailand
is hooked how many of these ladies are
here because of drugs
it's an industry worth tens of billions
of dollars
every year a deadly addiction
with devastating consequences
call it what you will but asia pacific
is the world's biggest methamphetamine
market
and thailand is the drugs highway
so how do authorities here when the war
on meth
okay thailand is fighting
a bitter battle and this navy team
is on the front line the enemy
drug cartels trafficking meth this allow
myanmar and thai is a tree country
and this is where the drugs come across
yes exactly
earlier asia's meth trade is worth an
estimated
61 billion dollars a year and this spot
on the mekong river
where thailand and its neighbors borders
meet
is a gateway to the region this is the
golden triangle a hub
for organized crime in southeast asia
with drugs people
animals and money being smuggled across
this river
trafficking levels rocketed in 2020
with cheap meth from factories in
myanmar flooding the market
if you spotted something suspicious on
the river
what do you do
foreign
drug smugglers don't just use the mekong
river
thailand's lengthy land border with
myanmar is remote
but porous possible to cross if you know
where to target
again the military stands guard playing
an
endless game of cat and mouse against a
constant
flow of traffickers this gives you
an impression of just how difficult it
is
to patrol these areas and spot
drug smugglers we've got thick the
jungle
river can you imagine how hard it would
be to spot someone coming through here
at night
at checkpoints border patrol is also on
the lookout
smugglers will try anything to evade
them
i mean if you look at a truck like this
there are so many places to hide drugs
so
inside obviously potentially under the
seat in the glove box
maybe into the doors and then here they
say that people
attach boxes under here packed with
pills
potentially in the gas chamber here as
well the tyres
these can be stuffed and then of course
you've got the whole
back of the van or truck as well there
are two types of methamphetamine being
moved
crystal which is purer and more
expensive
and yabar which contains about 20 meth
cut with
caffeine and comes in cheap pink little
pills
both extremely addictive they have the
potential
to ruin lives oh well i
um pretty much died the day i got here
and got brought from hospital i was
screaming out for help at my place
because i knew i was gonna die um
because i've been a hospital like eight
times
and um so i quickly just send a message
to a friend
which i'm dying now man it's um it's
it's i'm going now
just call an ambulance john not his real
name has abused both ice
and yabbar he's now in private treatment
hoping to finally break free of meth
at its peak he was taking up to 30 pills
a day
spending 5000 pounds a month desperately
trying to hang on to the high
the easy way out is just bang for hell i
had a gun i would have killed myself
did it make you violent i mean i ended
up in jail because i tried to burn
someone
alive they call ice the devil's drug
because it really just takes everything
you have it takes your soul
you know what i mean so everything that
you know to be good in life
i'm gonna exchange it for that high
accounts for three-quarters of all drug
addicts and treatment in thailand
at a christian charity they sing about
the vicious
pills patients here go
cold turkey no drugs no booze
no caffeine no phones
they're isolated from their families
sometimes
for months
literally means crazy drug it's highly
addictive
and gives users massive highs huge
energy surges
and then crippling lows thailand
historically has had a matthews problem
but it's really exploded
uh the last few years right now meth is
the cheapest it has ever been
in terms of you know purchasing power
you're talking it's almost free
it's that cheap to buy a hit it has a
huge effect on the public health system
we don't see this anywhere else in the
world this level of methods
the booming trade has lined the pockets
of asia's meth millionaires
until recently it's claimed one drug
lord in his network
controlled whole communities in the
hills along this border
under the cartel most of her life taking
and selling meth
most of her neighbors did the same
fighting back
wasn't an option
[Music]
how worried were you for your safety did
you ever see anyone
get attacked
the arrest of the drug baron was the
authority's chance to break the grip of
the cartel
with their help lay found new work and
income
away from drugs but as officials drive
us through the areas that used to be
ruled by gangs
their shadow can still be felt
the authorities have told us that around
99 percent of people
living here used to be involved in the
drug trade whether that was taking drugs
or dealing them and although they've
been working hard to turn the area
around they've actually said it's not
safe for us to get out of the car and be
seen
filming on the streets cartels are
deliberately creating addicts
flooding thailand with pills costing
less than a packet of crisps
one boot or backpack can be used to
smuggle
thousands of tablets putting huge
pressure
on police forces
wow so this is what 6.7 million
tablets of yabba looks like authorities
swept a staggering
352 million yebar tablets off the
streets last year
and is this your biggest tool to date
but unlike heroin cartels don't need
farms or huge workforces to make this
if these tablets had been sold on the
streets here in thailand they could have
made a minimum
of around 8.5 million pounds which is a
huge amount of money to lose
but the reality is the cartels can make
more
one tablet cost just under a penny to
produce
for many caught up in the trade there is
no second
chance this is kanchanaburi jail
here meth's legacy is laid back
around 79 of thailand's female
inmates are serving time for charges
relating to crystal and yebba
it's the reason the country has the
second highest rate of female
incarceration
in the world
how many of these ladies are here
because of drugs
clear to see a crackdown on drugs has
packed
thailand's prisons to the point of
overcrowding
200 women sleep on this cell floor
[Applause]
here they're teaching them new skills to
stop them falling back into drugs on
release
helping them build savings for when they
get out
ue is training to be a fortune teller
it's going to be okay
caught with more than 400 yaba pills she
got a 10 year sentence
monkey
[Music]
[Music]
poverty or addiction push many here
towards math
[Music]
and so the cycle continues defenses
are stepped up seizures are at record
levels
but supply seems unaffected
they say where they put in these patrols
that the number of people
trying to smuggle drugs across has
dropped but the reality is
they have more than 4 000 kilometers of
land border to patrol here
and one person can carry tens of
thousands of tablets
just seems like a totally impossible
task
the ongoing flood of dirt cheap meth is
stacking up victims
overwhelming the prisons overstretching
the police
and the health system in thailand's
latest war on drugs
a long and difficult fight lies ahead